television is great for telling
serialized stories over a long period of
time but not every TV series is meant to
last whether it's because of stiff
competition upheaval at the network or
simply being ahead of their time some
shows are canceled before they have a
chance to reach their full potential
none of these series made it past a
single season and we still aren't over
it
Clone High the animated MTV show clone
high followed clones of Abraham Lincoln
JFK Cleopatra and Gandhi among other
famous historical figures each
reinvented as a different teenage
archetype as they try to manage hormones
homework and a secret government program
with evil designs on their school she's
a user like [ __ ] you gir like a pair of
breasts the show's irreverent humor and
use of real-life historical figures were
bound to lead to controversy and its
depiction of Gandhi as a horny party
animal led hundreds of Indian citizens
to go on a hunger strike in protest
after the controversy the show was
ultimately cancelled with no hope of
renewal still while it ended too soon
for many fans the show's single season
remains a fascinating time capsule of
early 2000s MTV animation my so-called
life following Claire Danes character
Angela chase and her friends as they
dealt with real timely issues like
homophobia and abuse my so-called life's
depiction of teenage life was genuinely
groundbreaking from great dialog to well
written characters the show established
a unique depiction of a high-schooler
search for identity James's performance
was sometimes uncomfortably familiar and
the show's unflinching look at the less
discussed aspects of adolescence was a
critical hit he's bisexual
how can he be by anything he's a child
he's obviously very confused he's not
confused
he wears eyeliner unfortunately while
the show was beloved by its fans
James was ready to move on to new things
by the end of the first season and low
ratings meant the show was unlikely to
get a second season with or without her
still its influence reverberating
through nearly every high school set
series that followed Firefly
when discussing shows cancelled before
their time it's basically impossible to
exclude Firefly the show's focus on
science fiction adventures fused with
Western sensibilities combined with
creator Joss Whedon's trademark dialogue
made a huge impact on
those fans proved it with their now
legendary campaigns to save the series
which eventually resulted in a
big-budget movie continuation serenity
like any sci-fi series elements of
Firefly arguably haven't aged well but
it still remains a joy to see Zoe and
wash is one of the only functional
couples on the show there is traumatized
and cynical as the rest of the crew but
nonetheless refused to let their pass to
find them just one reason fireflies one
season voyage remains the focus of a
devoted fanbase the tick the original
live-action the tick followed the
addle-brained hero and his frustrated
former accountant turned super sidekick
Arthur using a mix of Seinfeld style
humor and off-brand Justice League type
antics to introduce a host of ridiculous
characters baby the madcap comedic
stylings and patrick warburton 'he's
booming voice have become almost
inseparable from the DNA of modern
comedies but the tick only lasted one
season while the show's run might have
been short it was definitely sweet with
a whole host of ridiculous allies and
enemies menacing our favorite bulging
blue bug evil never sleeps mr. Madoff
Quibbler although it's great that Amazon
resurrected the property without
Warburton and the rest of the original
cast on board the original takes
cancellation still feels like a missed
opportunity The Adventures of Brisco
County jr. starring the one and only
Bruce Campbell as Brisco The Adventures
of Brisco County jr. mixed classic
Western tropes like train robberies and
corrupt juries with anachronistic
technology like Rockets and projectors
much of the charm came from Campbell's
distinctive comic timing in every man
persona but the scripts were
surprisingly clever the show was set in
1893 a full 100 years before its airing
in 1993 which allowed for all sorts of
Futurama esque winking at popular
culture filtered through the lens of
classic genre trappings anyone who loves
Campbell's work or can simply appreciate
a perky good time needs to see this cult
classic the get-down Baz Luhrmann's the
get-down was always going to be subject
to scrutiny
Lerman is a love him or hate him
director and when you add in the massive
price tag and the difficult to define
genre the show is destined to leave some
of you are scratching their heads the
get-down tried to tell an unusual kind
of magical realist story about the
search for mythical wrecker
and passionate musical performances that
could convert foe to friends even when
the show approached abstraction its core
trio of kids in the slums of New York
brought an emotional reality that bed
rocked the series the way I see it all
of us here on this planet and we're on a
journey and it is a mystery
sadly the show just never found enough
of an audience but the entire run is
still part of the Netflix lineup just
waiting for the right viewers to get
hooked on its musical myth freaks and
geeks many shows have taken place in
highschool but none with the level of
uncomfortable frank honesty that fueled
freaks and geeks brought to viewers by a
flock of future famous faces and writers
including Judd Apatow Seth Rogen Linda
Cardellini Jason Segel and James Franco
it offered a unique depiction of
adolescence yeah well what are you gonna
do I don't know what are you gonna do
it's stunning to look back on the show
and see the on-screen evolution of some
of our favorite talent but even more
impressive is the timelessness of the
stories in the way they're delivered
although it was set in the early 80s
freaks and geeks remains eternal because
of its willingness to embrace the
awkward acne ridden side of being a
teenage misfit
[Music]